[Music]
families still breathing after the two
deadly Boeing 737 max plane crashes are
testifying on Capitol Hill for the first
time this morning there is growing
concern the grounded aircraft may not be
ready to fly again until 2020 346 people
died in the two crashes in Indonesia and
Ethiopia Kris Van Cleave spoke to the
family of one of the victims and he's on
Capitol Hill for us Chris an emotional
day for them good morning
well good morning emotions certainly are
running high as the families appear
before the House Transportation
Committee the committee has been hearing
from various stakeholders involved in
the 737 max grounding an investigation
but not directly from families and
that's prompted some to demand a chance
to be heard by lawmakers Sam you stew mo
was just 24 years old when she boarded
Ethiopian flight 302 in March the Boeing
737 max crashed minutes after takeoff
killing all 157 people on board involved
with the process michael stew mo is
samia's father two pilots don't have the
strength to overcome what the plane is
doing to try to ram it in the ground in
this case at 500 miles an hour where our
daughter's body parts got mixed with
other people's body parts and plane
parts and mixed with the dirt
investigators believe a faulty sensor
triggered the plane's anti-stall system
pushing the aircraft into a dive a
similar set of circumstances is believed
to be the cause of the lion air 737 max
crash last october in indonesia which
killed 189 people stu mosz mother Nadia
we need to see the pain and the families
that lost people because that is the
price they keep talking about the price
from Boeing how much they're losing in
terms of revenue this is the human cost
testifying alongside Michael stumer will
be Paul Giroux gay he lost his entire
family when flight 302 fell from the sky
he says he was so grief-stricken he
hasn't been able to bring himself to go
back to his family's canada home my
family died because of Boeing's
negligence arrogance management what I
call management dysfunction and lack of
internal office
we've been bullying our purpose is to
understand what happened in the accident
so we can make flying even safer in May
Boeing CEO Dennis Muhlenberg spoke
exclusively with CBS Evening News anchor
Norah O'Donnell in some cases that means
understanding that leads us to
improvements in the airplane design such
as the software improvement and we own
that we have that responsibility Boeing
software engineers are working to
resolve design issues with the 737 max
but there's growing concern the
grounding could stretch into 2020 the
families have made clear they don't want
to see the 737 max fly again until all
of the investigations are complete if
ever again
now the max has been grounded longer
than any other fleet of airplane in the
FAA s history and there is growing
concern in some aviation circles that it
may not fly passengers until sometime in
2020 Boeing says it regrets the loss of
life and has continued to apologize to
the families for the accident Gail I'm
sure an apology is not enough you know
it's so important to remind people about
the human cost yeah young man my age you
think of your own family yes everybody
lose your entire children his wife and
his mother-in-law can't even go home do
you saw the victim's mother - the woman
who turned away when her father was
husband was talking about body parts and
human parts and plane I have to relive
all that today's gonna be too much
really painful let's hope they get that
right